hello i'm andrew lee an omnics logic
fellow and an intern at columbia
university this summer
my project is coding an app in art using
single cell rna-seq fetal brain samples
for the identification of potential
autism risk genes
autism is a neurological condition that
causes limitations in social
communication repetitive and compulsive
actions and also declines in cognitive
ability
there is a high prevalence of autism as
around one percent of total population
has this condition
the similar clinical symptomatology of
neurological disorders also leads to
common misdiagnosis of autism
this is a problem because it serves as a
barrier for the creation of accurate
individualized treatments
and also occupational therapy programs
and learning arrangements depend on
accurate diagnosis
the current methods of diagnosis are the
dsm 5 and genetic testing the dsm-5 is
considered the gold standard diagnostic
criteria used by physicians today
however several studies have indicated
that the dsm-5 is overly broad with its
criteria
as you can see on the right
this is a flowchart of how autism is
diagnosed from the behavioral monitoring
to the genetic testing
and the genetic testing is highly
dependent on discovering new autism-rich
genes
recent studies has estimated that a
thousand or more genes cause autism
however there have only been a hundred
genes are confirmed
a more recent approach is through
machine learning to identify genes that
have similar expression profiles to
already confirmed autism genes
for my project i want to first identify
potential autism risk genes using an
unsupervised machine learning approach
next i want to identify those genes that
have similar expression profiling among
autism-related cell clusters
and this would eliminate some of the
coincidental connections caused by the
unsupervised methods
next i want to improve my research and
the research of others by creating a
publicly available app with a
user-friendly interface that only
requires a single gene name to result in
clear visualization and plots
of more than 20 types of human cells
my data sets for this was an a-risk
asset from chennai 2020
there were two groups of data first was
the human fetal brain sample readings
and the next was the prefrontal cortex
samples
for the identification of possible
autism-related genes i first conducted a
heat map and principal component
analysis
the plots were annotated with around 200
to 200 genes and 121 of those were from
the spark autism database
the app was coded in r using shiny and
shiny dashboard packages and some of the
code was modified from the omnixlogic
biotech transcriptomics course
to continue with the methods i first
used a t-distributed stochastic neighbor
embedding plot the disney plot
and next i also did violin plots to use
single gene inputs to generate
expression levels for more than 20
distinct cell types
and the next was a ridge plot which is
just an alternative to the single gene
to see
the expression levels were then compared
with those of known autism-rich genes
and the genes with similar expression
profiling were determined as possible
autism irish genes
so you can see a schematic of how the
process was conducted first let's use
expression matrix and then the heat map
and principal component analysis with
hierarchical clustering was made
this gave me a list of genes to further
analyze and this i manually inputted on
the app that i created
and this created violin pot disney plots
and ridge plots
and this i compared to the known
autism-rich genes to develop a final
list of candidate autism genes
for the heat map and principle component
analysis with hierarchical clustering
you can see that the risk genes are
clustered near the top with high
functional scores and these are genes
that have already been evaluated as
autism genes
however 10 genes listed were not already
labeled as autism genes and they were
also clustered near the top and you can
see this with the purple and blue
coloring
and this means that they can potentially
serve as candidate autism-rich genes
you can see a similar expression
profiling on the pc-1 of the principal
component analysis
the austen rich genes in blue are
grouped together however you can see
several red dots and these indicate that
these genes are also similarly expressed
these genes from the heat map and
principle component analysis were listed
for the next step in verifying that they
are indeed risk genes
to narrow this down i used a single gene
expression from the app i coded
all the genes from the previous step
were manually inputted one by one into
the coded app and they generated three
plots as you can see from the example
chd 4 which is a known autism gene above
you can see that chd 4 had high
expression in many of the cell clusters
that are linked to autism and also in
terms of the scores where they are on
the tisny plot you can see that is
highly expressed in many cell clusters
and this process was verified for each
of the genes and if they had one
low expression levels or two were not
expressed in autism-related cell types
they were excluded
on their right you can see the cell type
plots and these were the umap and also
the complete gene disney
while they do not help in autism risk
identification you can see that the
cells can be clearly grouped into 26
distinct cell clusters
my research conclusions
is that the app provides automatic plot
rendering and image downloads and this
means that the user can easily visualize
single genes the app is also useful for
other researchers that can want to
correlate genes of interest to
expression levels between cell types
for this study i correlated the
application to autism-risk genes and you
can see that on the heat map and the
principal component analysis there was
apparent clustering of the known autism
genes
and also on the heat map clustering
however there were also some genes that
were
not known as autism risk genes before
but were also grouped with these and
after applying the two selection
criteria five genes were identified as
potential autism-rich genes
these may also be markers of autism on
their right you can see the list of the
five genes identified the discovery of
autism-rich genes can clearly improve
the genetic testing available for autism
which provides more clear and accurate
diagnosis
in the past genetic testing has been
limited by the lack of autism-rich gene
knowledge and the amount of data that's
available for some limitations of my
study
is that brain expression similarities
can often be coincidental and further
functional analysis is needed to verify
that any of the genes are indeed
autism-rich genes
supervised machine learning approaches
and also neural networks can provide
more
autism autism-risk gene discovery and
reduce their risk of false positives
from my future research
this analysis has proved useful in
identifying the five candidate autism
genes but i also want to study their
biological and molecular functions
to extend my project further i want to
continue adding more recent and larger
data sets to use in the app and the
unsupervised gene machine learning
methods i would like to thank mr ellia
brodsky dr harpreet carr and my mentors
at columbia university
thank you for listening